it thanks very much I just attended the
session on the global energy context and
it was interesting to say the least
because while the prior year's topic was
scarcity and how to deal with energy
scarcity this session is all about
abundance fascinating to find out that
now natural gas is abundant not only in
North America but becoming a wave and in
china in the interesting debate in a
session was the climate versus energy
consumption and given now that natural
gas is growing by a four or five percent
of North America doesn't seem to be much
of its debate anymore as gas is
displacing coal and fifty percent less
emissions so for once in the history of
the industry it looks as though that
climate a movement and the energy
movement can at least agree on one point
that gas is growing gases is improving
and it's displacing coal and that's for
the good of the planet so quite a big
shift from the last couple years here at
Davos